la realities of musical masterminds
worked with Mariah pink usher Bieber
Whitney but for him Gaga is the one who
got away it was difficult seeing lady
gaga become lady gaga went gaga first
performed for Reed he told her she would
change music but after hearing her demo
tape he passed and before you know it it
was Gaga's world by that time I I was
about this big I felt like I'd shrunk
about this big but big is what la is all
about today he's the CEO of Epic Records
he got there by finding unknown singers
and turning them into pop icons gonna be
one less lonely but you signed 14 year
old justin bieber to his former Island
Def Jam record label la orchestrated
Mariah's come back and launched the
careers of Rihanna Usher and pink who
gave him a little dig on one of her
first records la told me you'll be a pop
star
oh you have to change is everything you
are and reap does take some of the blame
for this crack is whack I thought that
I'd failed Whitney honestly because you
know it was something that I helped to
arrange in his new book sing to me read
discusses his role in Whitney Houston's
now infamous 2002 interview with Diane
Sawyer I made two went to plan to ever
saw craft let's get that straight okay
there's a star nurturer sometimes I try
to protect people and that was one of
those times when I feel like I failed at
it well la is also the guy who
discovered Meghan Trainor she is up for
a Best New Artist Grammy this year and
she's also look for a Kids Choice Award
as favorite female singing I get this
she's going against Adele Ariana Mickey
Selena and Taylor not too bad see who
wins March twelfth and Nickelodeon